I am scheduled to have a dreaded dental feeling tomorrow.
Your advice when I asked previously was to not do detox a couple of days before the
feeling would then apply to the cancer program and the dental overnight program.
No, you can still run all those, run your cancer program, run your dental overnight program.
If you, I think it was you that asked the question that you have hard time with the dental
products that will help numb the tissue, all the different products that are in the market
that they're going to use to different numb the tissue and stuff and that can be an issue.
If you're using doing a lot of detox before that, it's going to make it worse.
I think that's what you referred to. I think you asked a question a few weeks ago.
But definitely run any the dental overnight, the dental folkae programs, the dental infection programs.
I would run those. I would honestly, I would probably before this, I'm going to skip the cancer program
tonight, just run those overnight and then when you get home, put the bulb right up to the area
and your bulb to just run those programs as best you possibly can do that.